actually I brought some gifts oh you did
damn all right some
vitamins oh wait why did she bring this
what what me I feel like uh maybe we're
a bit tired you know GN just flew here
if you're tired gone you should
definitely drink this okay okay what's
this one so these are some really fancy
things I don't no you haven't really
said that in Japan but in every comini
there's like a wall of these little
liquids and they're supposed to be drank
like before drinking or after
drinking what [__] this is like a give
you energy this is [__] yeah I actually
I actually drink one of these every
morning now oh it actually works better
for me than a
coffee I drank one this morning and I'm
feeling good so that's really good wait
wait
Mak Mak Maka is like U the hell is Mak
it's like a yeah ex extract what the
hell are you popping it open yeah this
one is EP this is also for like I think
this is more so for um hangovers and
stuff like that this is like a liver
kind of drink so it helps cleanse your
liver after a night I drink it you drink
this before you start drinking yeah
that's not an enery drink that's a
that's a hangover cure yeah yeah I was
like oh [__] is mud bringing us like
vodka or something when you bought out
the Yukon I'm like oh my God we call
these magic potions but why does it
taste like Red Bull just uh all of them
taste like Red Bull so like yeah PE one
time had this cuz uh there's a drink
called uh oron Oram I never can never
[__] say orami it's basically just an
energy drink but I guess it's looks like
a vitamin like kind of a like a medicine
bottle and Pete was like man I used to
drink those all the time when I was sick
I'd have like four of them I was like
Pete you know there's like 20 grams of
sugar in one of those he's like oh I
guess I did feel
something maybe that's why I felt sick
yeah I was like yeah if you drink four
energy drinks when you feel sick you're
G you're not going to feel much better
you're [__] gone bro God I remember
Christ yeah so that's Maka apparently is
also good for um uh erectile dysfunction
[Laughter]
MAA apparently it gets you like Mega
hard so uh wait what gets you hard or is
it it keeps it keeps I'll give you an
update in 20 that's the trash day
special right
there entire trash day epode but we're
all rock take a Viagra and you will
never know which episode it is is is
Viagra over the counter in Japan I have
no idea I very much doubt in the UK they
like a few years ago they made it over
the counter really you can just rock up
to the store and by Viagra what just
like at a convenience store yeah really
yeah damn so this episode
is
good my penis is healthy yeah but I very
much doubt it just because there's a
like a lot of stuff that are over the
counter in other countries it's just a
lot harder to find in Japan very much
this s just kind of wild just having a
rock hard penis completely out of your
control but Viagra is only prescription
Bas prescription prescription
my my favorite like insane muden fact
that you told me that I don't know if
you still do this you told me that you
were spending like $1,000 a month on
Fiverr just finding editors oh no that
was a long time ago like at the
beginning yeah that's crazy so run run
through that like how did you well
Connor was like all right I'm going to
do a highlights Channel I'm going to
need editors and I'm like okay I can
handle it and then he was like all right
5 hours of footage he's like all right
how about two videos a week can you do
more can you do four videos a week I'm
like no
please but uh I just needed editors fast
so I went through fivr I I spent so much
time on Fiverr trying to find different
editors I would say it's I found some
really solid editors there like really
talented who are still with me but I
would say out of like 50 people that you
test you find one person who fits and
that's where you're like sometimes I'd
spend two grand and I wouldn't even get
like a video that's usable at all right
right right Jesus Christ so did you find
that there was a correlation between how
much you paid and how good the editor
was yeah just it's so i' pay like you
know there's a people who don't charge
much so they'd be like all right I do it
for $10 and then person who's like I do
it for 200 both same quality really yeah
like
literally so [__] funny if it costs
over 100 probably
[__] it's it's like the people in the
middle who are like 50 around $50 those
are good so you find those a lot of them
ALS do it just to like get the foot in
the door so there have been some people
who are like yeah I'm doing it right now
just to have my name out there and who
have actually like helped and now
they're editing for like beer YouTubers
as well who started at $50 now they're
making you know a couple Grands I mean I
think the biggest thing about being a
YouTuber at least for me personally
because you know we do work with a lot
of editors as well uh it's finding the
consistency uh and finding someone who
understands YouTube editing cuz I think
YouTube editing is very very different
from traditional media editing if if
somebody does traditional media I'm
instantly like no that that doesn't work
cuz relearning is like almost impossible
but you can't teach somebody from
scratch yeah uh question right away what
is one of the videos of ours that you've
edited that just makes you shutter when
you think about it it's just like the
video you're like not again any of our
videos it's probably be I probably full
I'm probably the Japan special right
yeah well yeah that was toally that was
so huge I guess trash T special always
like it's so fun when I'm in it but it's
it's kind of like same with video games
like you want to get into it and you you
know you're going to spend the next 6
hours of your life at least 6 hours
minimum if you don't have 6 hours of
free time you're not going to start on
it but I never have 6 hours of free time
right so it's really hard to like get
into the mindset of it right cuz usually
on a daily basis I go through like 10 20
videos and uh there just not enough time
to like well you'll just open a video
for 5 minutes and be like all right next
video no what do you mean you said 10
videos right are you opening a video for
like 30 minutes at a piece and then just
I mean it can be like 10 minutes some
can be 2 hours it depends like my job
right now like I I'm mostly the glue
that holds everything together I'm I'm
like the quality control so sometimes
like yeah I go over the video I'm like
all right that's cool uh maybe I just
change one or two things and sometimes
I'm like all right well that's like 4
hours of my work just to like get it up
to
par so is there a video that you look
back on that you've edited for like any
of us that you're like this is this was
this was a tough one this was a tough
one I are there any like types of videos
where you're just like oh God this is
going to be a anime videos I hate them
so
much no like what you do is fine now but
I would happy to know I would say that
that old type where you're like all
right so I'm going through Full Metal
Alchemist in this episode 36 uh they did
that thing and you'd be like all right
well I have to get the raw footage I
have to go through the entire season
find that one specific moment just for
that two seconds and then I have to do
it again like 100 times I remember when
we did the hentai special I I just
handed you all the hentai yeah and then
I guess you had to go through it for the
patreon version and play the bits we
were talking about that was pretty easy
compared to like stuff because there
only a couple of episodes right yeah
this is why Mudan doesn't edit for my
channel you know how does Allan Do It um
so we he gets paid monthly
yeah he has a salary which uh you know I
there's a big difference between how we
paid Mudan like or I guess how we paid
Mudan right now which is kind of like
more of a project for project basis
where for me and the editing team I have
for my channel it's a salaried kind of
based okay uh because I soon realized
that having them watch anime takes time
and it's weird to get build for someone
being like it took me 10 hours to watch
this many episodes of anime to find the
right footage yeah you do forget that
sometimes yeah yeah yeah cuz you don't
really fact that in when you're editing
you know obviously the footage where
you're not it's not technically on the
timeline they're just kind of like maybe
they need to watch it to get familiar
with the material so I was just like I
think a salari kind of like position
works better than a freelance position
because having to track your time when
you're like just watching anime it just
it tracks a lot harder as well yeah for
sure for sure yeah but I I got I I
always wanted to ask what was your
opinion when you edited the first Trash
taste episode and not like not like the
first one we released so the zero yeah
episode zero so the patreons will know
this we upload we recorded like an
episode zero uh where if you want to see
that
patreon.com uh where it was just like us
doing a it it was mostly just like
camera setup test where we're just
setting up to see if it looks good we
recorded and then we kept talking until
like the camera went out even though it
was like only meant to be a test to see
how Mudan could uh make it look what was
your initial reactions when uh when you
first saw like the trash taste and uh
what we were going to be doing damn
that's
easy so finally something easy finally
something easy to do before that I had
like a similar type of uh content that I
was making and it was so intense and so
hard so like trash taste kind of helped
me pivot from that to like this which is
much easier and uh yeah I like it you
also handled it pretty well like there
was no awkwardness the like walls were I
guess weirdly
and looking back yeah because we didn't
have any like background right yeah the
camera right now is like really natural
and in at the beginning it also seemed
really natural how it was so flat
looking back it's like wo that's weird
yeah yeah yeah when when I when I look
back to like our first like first season
trash taste episodes and this it goes to
the center camera I'm just like wao I
don't remember the camera looking like
that like well it was really far away
cuz we didn't have well we didn't have
much money so we kind of just had a
camera that had a I think a 24 mm lens
which made it have to just be like at
the end of the room which gives it this
really weird look yeah of like you can
tell it's far away but very it's very
very interesting and no one could go in
the middle of the room like everyone had
to be in the corners cuz if you went
through the middle you'd be walking past
I don't remember what we even talked
about on that like pilot episode I don't
remember either it was it was a long
time ago what what's been your favorite
trash taste video to edit all the
specials all the specials I just I well
I love the specials it's literally like
the closest to TV shows that you make
and I also can well I love trash taste
cuz you don't have me like force me to
do anything it's like full creative
freedom so I can experiment with
whatever yeah well because everything
you produce is Banger yeah it's it's all
based on a trust system right which is
very
important yeah I I mean that's pretty
much what keeps me going like the
creative freedom cuz the moment that
somebody's like all right here's like
five sheets of exactly what you have to
do that's when I'm like okay this is a
job now uh I don't want to do it yeah
cuz like I remember it's it's funny that
you said that about anime footage cuz I
remember I think how we found you was
you were originally an anime YouTuber
right anime uh like how when I mean you
still kind of make you I can't remember
what was the last anime video you've
actually like made on your personal
Channel cuz Mudan does actually have a
personal Channel and personal streams
which you do to I guess figure out the
logistics and the landscape of the other
editing projects that you're going to be
doing I guess when did you stop doing
anime content I think like 3 years ago 3
years ago it was well I didn't want to
do it anymore right cuz I was not
passionate
about happens to everyone eventually
except for this guy I mean yeah well you
go through so much anime everything
seems repetitive and then also like if
you do reviews it's like what new can I
say to this like I don't have that
natural Charisma or like ideas to bring
to the table without going too stale
yeah but I think when I found you what
what said you apart immediately from a
lot of other anit tubers was just like
again like you had this like it wasn't
just like a sit in front of a camera do
a review type of thing you know go
through episodes throw on a joke that
kind of stuff like you know I think what
made like you and you know in the same
way that made Gant uh very unique in the
antiu sphere was just that you guys had
like your own flavor that made it
instantly like this is a giga video or
like this is a moodon video and in your
case you were just like going so BS to
the walls with your editing I I remember
I was just like every like 3 seconds it
was just like oh there's an After
Effects thing there's an after effect it
like it it just seemed like so over the
top but I think that was like one of the
big reasons why I like decided to like
get you to edit for me was just like no
one in the antibe sphere is editing like
this you know no one's making videos
like this and I think that's what kind
of set you apart from everyone else you
know yeah well when I started anitube I
only did it for two reasons cuz uh I
like what I wanted to be a YouTuber in a
way uh but I didn't have much to talk
about so it was either video games or
anime there like the two hobbies and
already did video games for like a year
and that got nowhere so I was like all
right anime [__]
it why did you go for video games first
uh I don't know it's more basic
everybody does it I wanted to see if it
works but I think the big issue was I
did not really I guess commit to the
community cuz I did not speak to anybody
and in a year of like doing videos I did
not grow at all but I did learn like a
lot of important stuff with for editing
so when I started anbe I actually went
to like Community boards interacted with
members did like community events and it
was really fun and that's how I met a
lot of people I think maybe like some of
you as well through some of that yeah I
can't remember when I first met you must
have been some Anime Expo I think it's
always anime when you know the anime
Community was still a thing and people
met up at Anime Expo uh old
days the good old days